I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense see out of obviously fit you had
like more of a healthy book and why'd
you why damn it
I try and be original but I really want
to know cuz I'm super into fitness
so you know that question but like sure
yeah and so you subject people yeah well
what are they yeah I mean when do you
have a time that you stop at or do you
just try and have a few hours before you
go to bed
yeah yeah we go out eating and drinking
that's a lifestyle shift that's a big
life yeah yeah right but you know what
happens yeah yeah you go back because I
always I mean my hope with my book
because there's there's recipes there's
a workout program there's there's the
mental side of things too is like
yeah I don't have the chocolate chips in
them but they are in there and is that I
wanted people to stop looking at it as a
diet basically like what you're saying
like stop looking at is a temporary
thing I said if you want if you if you
do this program for 90 days and you eat
this way we do the workouts you're gonna
lose weight period like you just are but
what are you gonna do after that so
people if any if anyone were asked I'm
sure they would say I want to look good
for life so you got to figure out how
you're gonna make why are you gonna do
it that's gonna last for life not like I
want to lose 12 pounds because you can I
think there's a I think we're going back
in time I think the days of like quick
food and fast food and processed food I
think it's going I don't know I get if I
feel like we're getting more of that
farm-to-table kind of local ingredients
and ingredients with integrity I don't
know I see that a lot in the restaurant
world it's a it's a it's a good thing
because I think for a long time there
was many decades where it was all about
the faster the better and food means
something to me I'm I I can't throw
things away because once I've made it
I'm like I put love into that can't
throw it away
[Music]